ああああーーん
こちらネタネタ超会議炎上ブースからお届けしております本日はお集まりいただき
ありがとうございます
ユーチューバー肇社長の女子の金沢と
[音楽]
ん
も手だ
のテラー
今日の嫌いなのですがせっかくファンの皆様にお集まりいただいたので直接
皆さんの意見もいただきたく参考までに皆さんに動画のネタを考えて頂きたく思って
おります
しかし動画作りで難しくなるのは炎上のディスクでございます
youtube に動画を配信する際一番注意すべき点としてはその動画を配信する
ことによってユーザーに悪影響を及ぼさないか
真似すると危険ではないかなどの危険性を留意した上で enter を考えなければ
なりません
そこで今回は炎上について研究をしているプロフェッショナルの方をお招きしており
ます
ユーチューバー大学炎上学部教授の炎上教授ですどうぞ
[音楽]
クッポン
ええええええ
したん
皆様炎上教授はこれまで50年間炎上についての研究に取り組んでおりまして
いまだ謎が多い10%増のアルゴリズムと校則についての研究分野における先駆者と
言われております
先日発売された閻教授の著作本 enjoy ん炎上は全国20分の売り上げを出して
おります
ぜひ全国の書店でお求めくださいそれでは教授
自己紹介をよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
廉造です
まあ youtube の世界ね
[音楽]
塩蔵とようなでゾーンに
あるので
まぁ今回初めてそうだっけ
あああん
あの当時のデーターをちょっと考えてもらってね
まあそのいろんなネタがあると思うんだけども
円蔵の
ここは実
まあ
[音楽]
4日
それでは皆さんに早速ネタを考えていただきます
例えば水を2秒で3リットル飲んでみた
教授
こんなないようむメーターはどうでしょうかいやー塩蔵しますね
あの水というものはやはり
早飲みすれば危ないというか諦念一定量の成分を考案してしまうと人はあの
致死量になってしまうので危ないのでまぁそれはやめておいたほうがいいと思います
なるほど思い考えたがある方は挙手していただけますでしょうか
など大一番
マハンお名前重ねたら
の船長の間になるか
謎
とても素晴らしい音だと思うんですよ
勉強中
エアー多分塩蔵せますねー
生派では
手で重ねるんですか
あ p 1000とかまああの仮にまずピンセットに
バイ菌がついていると
ひょっとするとバイキンを取り込んでその可能性があって
病気になってしまうかもしれませんね
それを子供が真似してピンセットでルー
me
このような真似してピンセットで生を重ねて自分の心臓がですよとするとあの鐘知った
トドままでも
ピンセットバイキンで両耳になってしまうのでちょっとでメタをやめておいたほうが
いいかなぁ
やっても遅いねえっ
良いと思いますありがとうございます
ありがとうございました続いて他にネタがある方
ヨーヨーをん
謝罪した
童謡どんぐりころころ
これを完全再現してみた俺もオーナー
延長しますねーどんぐりが
池にはまるだけでもダメなんですまあ1形にもし
魚がいるとせません
そうすると
どんぐりころころしてきたどんぐり ud をエサと勘違いしてしまって食べですよ
そうなるとその魚さんにとっては致命傷になりかねない
そこでまた一つの命あ
うせ流れてするのでちょっと
避けていただきたいところでありますね
ありがとうございました
0姉母があります
4日
2列目の
[音楽]
狂って
をん
15インクを荒らさず朗読してみ
出て国語辞典を一言も漏らさず
朗読してみたこちらも炎上するんですかというです
これは遠藤しますねー
あの国語辞典分量が多いのでもしてこれが youtube を見ている子供たちが
植物体を全部本北
朗読するの真似してしまうと子どもたちの寝る時間が確保できなくて友達ノアの成長に
悪影響を及ぼすてしまうので女神ですね
[音楽]
多さから怒られるということですね
ありがとうございました次のメンターあることを持っ
9パンをくわえながら可能制服で曲がった web f
ありがとうございます食パンをくわえながら稼働全力で曲がったらどれくらいの確率で
人とぶつかるかありがとうございます
これはせ
きょう中
yeah
どう考えでしょうか
いやーこれは炎上しますねあのーが2点挙げられるんですけども
加えているパンドラっかによる
あのターンが汚れてしまってその他も仮にあの
スタッフがも美味しくいただけますかといったとしても
ばい菌が乗っている可能性があってバーそういう病気になってしまう可能性が
という危険性と佐渡あった時にぶつかっていた方との接触事故による
マッスルポーズこの可能性も少なからずあるので
それもちょっとレンズを束ねないかもしれないですね
初めて我慢しましょうありがとうございました次のネーターがある方をお願いします
ありがとうございますセンター試験を受けてみたジャンド word on
ん
これも炎上しますねー
せん断試験受けてみたん
やはり子どもを見ている方が重いので
もし子どもたちがセンター試験受けたい受けたいってなってしまうと
センター試験当日各地の会場に小学生があふれだすとに
図研もできないのに来てしまうと事件の棒がになって育ってこれまた社会問題になり
かねない非常に危険なネタやっております
でデータがいいかもしれないですねありがとうございましたん
いいのネタがある方ん
ポケモンゴーのアプリのアカウント凍結してみたん
wh
こちらどうでしょうかです
これ津波に誰の関東
自身で自分の後家数
これ店
どうしてまたそのようなこと2
そうですねこれがもし誰かが肇社長のポケモンゴーの担当を消すみたいになるとその人
にこの日の子が
館炎上になるんですけども自分自身で自分のファン等を消す頭があると
塩蔵しなさそうに
一見見えるんですけども
[音楽]
消されたポケモン無機物を考えてみてください
おじいちゃんでしょ
六本木ヒルズで晩成チャンスセンター
ん
eme
スポチャンとはどうでしょうかあの以前本人から聞いたんですけども
6本いるぞクソからプリンをとしてチャンツしてみたいと
お話をルームの形にしていったんですけども
奥造形はどうしてもやめてくれと
声がかかってしまい取っておいた方がいいかもしれん
くらいからだよ
24時間勉強してみるとどれくらい頭がよくなるのか
ちゃん動画はどうですか
こちらもひょっとしたらいうどしますかもしれないですね
キッズが
もせ真似して
勉強したい勉強したいたまま
24時間勉強するねやってしまうと学校に行かなくなってしまいまして
不登校率の促進につながってしまいますので
こちらもちょっとディ好きではないですかねやめておいたほうがいいかもしれないです
よ
室でだったらすいません
ただの屁理屈にすかっ
me
バッハ